welcome back we're now ready for
Newton's second law and Newton's second
law can simply be stated and you've
probably seen this before as force is
equal to mass times acceleration this is
probably if if not the most famous
formula in in all of time or all of
physics it's up there it's probably up
there with equals mc-squared but that
one's a little bit more complicated so
what does this tell us this tells us
that the force the net force upon an
object is equal to the object's mass
times its acceleration so let's say in
the metric system because most of what
you'll do in physics classes in the
metric system and that tends to be
because the metric system makes more
sense so let's say that I have a one
kilogram object let's say I have a one
kilogram object so it's mass is one
kilogram and it's being pulled down at
let's say its acceleration so it's being
it's being accelerated downward at 9.8
meters per second squared this should be
familiar need this kind of units these
kind of unit should be familiar with you
from all the projectile motion problems
so the force applied on that object in
order to get this type of acceleration
would be you just multiply mass times
acceleration the force would have had to
be 9.8 kilogram times the meter right
kilogram times meter over a second
squared that's the force applied on the
object and I say you're jinx al this is
very messy I don't like writing kilogram
meters per second squared and you are in
luck because there is a unit and that
unit is the Newton one Newton is equal
to one kilogram meter per second squared
so if I have if I'm pulling down on an
object at 9.8 Newton's 9.8 Newtons
that's just this right this is 1 Newton
if I'm pulling down 9.8 Newtons on an
object that is 1 kilogram
its acceleration is going to be 9.8
meters per second squared
down and notice I said the word down but
I didn't write it anywhere in the
formula and I guess we can imply that
both force and acceleration have
direction by writing by writing this in
the formula that forces a vector the
acceleration is a direct vector and so
we could have written 9.8 Newtons I know
this you'll never see this convention we
could say Newton's down is equal to one
kilogram times 9.8 meters per second
down so what can we do with this formula
well we can we can solve problems so
let's say that I have an object so my
object ways not ways right the mass of
my object and I'll differentiate between
weight and mass in a second let's say
the mass of some object is I don't know
50 kilograms that's how much a normal
person might weigh or a light person
mass weighs 50 50 kilograms and let's
say I were to and let's say we're in an
inertial frame of reference we're in
deep space so we don't have all these
other you know the force of wind and the
force of gravity acting on a six cetera
et cetera let's say that I apply a force
of my force let's say I apply it to the
right so we know that force is a vector
so let's say I apply a force of I don't
know 100 Newtons and let's say I apply
it to the right to the right so this is
the object 50 kilograms and I'm applying
a force to the right of 100 Newtons so
what's going to happen to this object
well let's use the formula force is
equal to mass times acceleration the
force is 100 Newtons 100 Newtons
is equal to the mass the mass is 50
kilograms 50 kilograms times the
acceleration
so we can divide both of the both sides
by 50 and you get 100 Newton's over 50
kilograms is equal to the acceleration
it's 100 Newton's to the right I mean I
use this little arrow here that's not a
traditional convention but that's why we
know it's to the right
so it's 105 divided by 50 so it's 2 we
get this weird we get this weird units
here Newton's per kilogram right is
equal to the acceleration to the right
this is also going to be to the right
because the direction of the force is
going to be the same as the direction of
the acceleration so what is this 2
Newton's per kilogram well if you
remember well you could just guess the
unit of acceleration is meters per
second squared but let's show that this
simplifies to that so we said earlier
that let me just switch colors that a
Newton is kilogram meter per second
squared and we're taking this Newton
over this kilogram over kilogram right
so that will cancel out with that and
you get meters per second squared and
you wouldn't have to do this on a test
you would essentially if you did
everything right you would know that the
unit of acceleration is meters per
second squared so you would have the
acceleration I'm just switching I'm just
switching the two sides is equal to 2
meters per second squared and it'll be
to the right to the right so that's
useful we just figured out based on how
hard I push something how fast it's
going to accelerate while I push it and
you could use the same formula to figure
out other things let's say let's say I
know that an object is accelerating
let's say my acceleration is 3 meters
per second squared to the right let's
say to the left just to switch things
and let's say that I know the force
being applied on it the force being
applied on it is I don't know 30 Newtons
to left and I want to figure out the
mass well you use the same thing you'd
say force 30
mutants to the left is equal to mass
times acceleration times 3 meters per
second squared to the left divide both
sides by the 3 meters per second and you
get 30 Newtons over 3 meters per second
squared is equal to the mass 30 divided
by 3 is 10 and then Newton's divided you
can figure out that Newton's is kilogram
meters per second squared so you're just
left with 10 kilograms is equal to the
mass and it's very it's very important
that you if you see a problem where the
answer is given in in you know I don't
know kilometers per second squared or
you know instead of giving it in
kilogram just giving it in grams or
decagrams you should convert back to
kilograms or meters just so they make
sure you're using the right units and
that tends to be frankly I think the the
hardest thing for people and will do all
of that when we tackle harder problems I
think now is a good time to actually
differentiate between mass and weight
and you've probably thought the two were
interchangeable but they're not mass is
how much of an object there is so you
know how many you can almost view it as
how much of the stuff there is or you
can almost you know how many atoms there
are but even atoms have mass so just how
much their stuff there is and another
way to view mass is how much does the
object resists change and that just that
actually falls out of F equals MA right
because if if our mass is bigger it's
going to take a lot more force to make
it accelerate a certain amount right if
the mass is smaller it'll take less
force so mass can be viewed as how much
stuff there is of an object there is or
it can you can view it as how hard is it
to change what that object is doing if
it's it if it's stationary how hard is
it to accelerate it if it's if it's
moving how hard is it to maybe stop it
which would essentially be decelerating
right how hard is it to accelerate an
object weight is actually how much is
what is the force of Earth upon an
object so your weight would actually
change if you go from one planet to
another because the force of gravity
changes so your weight is 1/6 on the
moon as it is on earth because the pull
of gravity is 1/6 but your mass doesn't
change there's still the
same amount of Sal on earth as there is
on on on the moon so your weight really
when you ask someone in Europe and they
say hey you know I weigh 50 kilograms
you should say no you don't weigh 50
kilograms you a whatever 50 times 9.8 is
that's like you know 400 something you a
400 what is 490 Newtons or something
right this is mass and it's interesting
because what in the English system and
all of us Americans we use the English
system when we say that we weigh 10
pounds we're actually using the correct
terminology because pounds are our unit
of force and so when we're saying you
know fi way and I do weigh about 150
pounds that means the earth is pulling
on the earth 150 pounds of force and
actually turns out that my mass is
measured in a unit called the slug which
we might discuss later actually we'll do
some problems where we do it in the
metric system and the English system
anyway I'll see you in the next
presentation